hello everyone today I wanna play guilt
which is a stadia exclusive I know very
little about it it's the only stadia
game that really interested me but I
also just wanted to talk about stadia I
made this video this one where I unboxed
the thing and gave my first impressions
and they were very positive and people
were unhappy about that because I think
the thing with stadia is that pretty
much no matter what people don't want me
to like it and that that makes it very
difficult to talk about so I wanted to
make I wanted to stream and just talk to
you guys about it candidly to clarify
some things which is that when I got
sent my stadia my expectations were
extremely low I didn't expect it to work
and when I got it I looked at it like a
early-access product obviously that's
not how it's been marketed people pay
pull full price for a thing that works
for some people and doesn't work for
others for the record it works really
well for me I'll show you guys I've had
like a couple of days where things
haven't wanted to be brilliant if today
was one of those days but for the most
part and my speeds are very good and I
am also just very interested in this
tech so I was very much wanting it to
work not that I want an old streaming
future because obviously that only works
for people like me who are lucky enough
to be in the right place to have it work
basically yes my ball was very low for
the thing I was impressed because it
worked and I think this tech is amazing
that's the thing is I went into this
very excited about the fact that that
this is tech that exists very excited
about the fact that I can play something
on my brow so literally anyway all I
have to do I'm gonna show you this is
obviously I've already done it but I
just go stadia stadia calm it's gonna
show you the exact same thing but then I
can immediately press play and this game
will play but there are a lot of things
that I have issues to do with when it
comes to stadia Cove 7s said I dislike
the video because as much as I realize
nothing one or a few many may have
troubles with it not saying a line or
anything it just wasn't very
representative how many will experience
it due to internet constraints see the
issue with that is does that mean that
you think that I should lie in a video
because other people had a different
experience to me
I think that's insane I think that I
should be completely
honest about what my experience is and I
think that anyone else who has a
positive experience should say the exact
same thing again Kolb 7s I actually he
said I think that if the issue seems to
be super common maybe you should mention
it I actually got my stadia at the same
time as everyone else so no reviews were
out it's just it's just not fair that uh
that I feel like people have been like
you know why don't you hate it you
should hate it I can talk about what I
hate about it
I think the pricing okay let me play the
[ __ ] game first Jesse I don't want to
let the hate control me like this is
this is a very very particular thing
when it comes to being someone in games
media is that people say that they want
honesty but they don't I know they don't
people want me to make negative videos
about Google stadia I know that
desperately because that will click
better they will trust me they will like
me more for it but I don't want to do I
just want to be honest I don't want to
do that I don't want to lie I think this
is like a horror game there's a little
black ball on that side that's just
because of where I have Google Chrome
situated currently this is me live
playing a stadia game on Google Chrome I
haven't touched this game at all but I
just pulled up Google Chrome and it
started perfectly immediately which was
consistent with every other game that
I've tried on Stadium
I think the pricing for stadia is
absolutely absurd it's frankly
ridiculous
[Music]
what is stranger things nonsense what's
going on here oh heck oh heck so I feel
like there's some framerate drops
they're no worse than any other video
game though I don't know I don't know a
man for what this isn't for how it works
my performance has been good has been
like if there are framerate drops like
that it has not been any worse than
[ __ ] Star Wars Jedi fallen Auto which
everyone loves but because this is on
Google stadia [ __ ] hate it oh I
shouldn't go through the water that's my
bed that's my bed so to the things that
I actually don't like about stadia I
don't have an issue with the fact that
you don't own the games because you
don't own the games on Steam either you
don't own anything that you download
digitally really you're just renting a
license that's how that [ __ ] works I'm
not gonna get mad at Google for doing
the same thing everyone else is doing I
praise them if they didn't do it but
it's it's just industry standard at this
point I think that the prices of games
are absolutely absurd I think paying the
same price for old games is ridiculous
and it can't work for them there's no
[ __ ] way that's going to pay off oh
no didn't want to do that nope back up
think that stadia should evolve to have
something like a game pass model it you
should not be this a dumb model but the
idea with it being a dumb business model
doesn't concern me terribly because
consumers can make the choice to just
not buy it right so like if you think
it's a dumb business model just don't
get one I feel like it's very easy for
you to look at the value of something
and be like oh I don't want that rather
than being like [ __ ] this thing burn it
to the ground
don't get ones even a weird thing is
they just don't subscribe just don't pay
for it
if you don't like the value just don't
do it that's that's not something it's
doing that is [ __ ] on consumers it's
just a bad deal for the people who have
chosen to buy it it's their fault for
buying it if it's a bad deal you can
[ __ ] see what the deal says my
concerns are related to the fact that
this thing has been made by Google how
does Google make their money ladies and
gentlemen ad revenue they are either
going to be the first ones to figure out
how to sell ads on video games and then
we're going to get pop-ups
in our cutscenes and or maybe you have
to watch a trailer to get to a new part
of a video game and I do not [ __ ]
want that and once Google does it and
they make it profitable everyone
we'll follow suit because the games
industry so goddamn money hungry
the reason the games industry spent
money hungry in a lot of ways is because
they compare themselves to other
entertainment industries so if you play
a hundred hours of Call of Duty which
you could easily do 500 even and you
only pay $60 Activision very openly
compares that to movie ticket sales and
they say someone watch something for
three hours or two hours or one and a
half hours and paid $15 that means to
Activision the video games are getting
screwed when it comes to the amount a
consumer pays per minute or per hour
versus the return of income compared to
other entertainment industries a play is
a really good example you go see theater
for two hours sometimes I can cost you
150 bucks for a ticket so Activision
execs look at that and say the games
industry is not getting enough money
when you consider the amount of time
people are spending playing the video
games we need to figure out ways to
monetize that time Google figuring out
how to put an ad in a cutscene or making
you watch an ad before you get to play
something or I don't know giving us
overlay and Alvear like I don't want
that at all that is one of my concerns
is that surely they want to figure that
out most of the money comes from ad
revenue I have no doubt that that's the
thing that they are going to be pursuing
and I find that extremely off-putting so
if they figure it out everyone else
figures it out video games have ads
which I'm sure they've wanted to do for
[ __ ] ages so what concerns me more is
that with video games being streamed
developers can figure out it was a bit
of a jump that exactly how you are
playing and how to keep you playing so
they will constantly have live data on
how you play every single [ __ ] video
game say you are playing apex legends
and you're playing it for I'm actually
pretty intrigued about what's happening
right now you're playing it for two
hours and you stop playing because
you've lost the game four times in a row
that would be very difficult considering
how long the average apex matches but
you get my point you lose four or five
times in a row and then you stop playing
they will have live data on the fact
that you stopped playing at that exact
in time and can absolutely manipulate a
video game in real time to keep you
playing they can make it and this isn't
illegal well not technically illegal and
it's very doable they can make it so
that they register your individual stats
the next game you play completely
against bots so that you keep playing
and you have no idea that you've done
that because they're getting all of this
data completely life they can manipulate
video games completely live we could
have people basically figuring out how
long it takes before you purchase
something and then setting up those
exact circumstances over and over and
over again to make you spend more money
on micro transactions or figuring out
how to get you to return to the same
game how do you increase the amount of
time you played they can just basically
manipulate user experiences to I think a
terrifying degree and it's that's the
part that concerns me the most about
this tech about stadia and about
Google's doing it because again Google
doesn't care about video games this is
the only exclusive game that they made I
feel like the frame rates like not yeah
no that's super smooth it is dropping
occasionally but I also like don't know
if that's stadia or if that's the game
it's kind of impossible to tell so
basically I'm just worried about how
video games going to change when it
comes to manipulating players to spend
more money the roughest said you're just
a geek excited by their technology that
is absolutely true I am and I think
people got very mad at me for being
excited about new technology because
they wanted me to [ __ ] on the thing that
is my bad I did not disclose no I did
actually at the start of the video I
think I was like I'm really excited
about this tank I did say that I never
hit that but it does mean that I was
always excited about it even if it's not
perfect and I I don't I don't know I
just feel like I had like communication
issues there yeah it's also just what's
talking about how I am viewing this
thing
and uh and the fact that it does work
for specific people and a lot of people
have been lying about it negatively he's
gonna [ __ ] me or we like are we cool it
got ruined by some shitty youtuber who
just reported falsely because he wanted
the fake [ __ ] headline that Google
stadia would only work if you had a
pixel phone you couldn't even set it up
on an iPhone so I got accused of faking
my setup because I completely used an
iPhone it 100% works on iPhone I don't
think you can stream games to the iPhone
but the set up works just fine so so not
only has there been people getting mad
at me for being positive but they're
they're also been people who've just
been overly negative about the thing
because it's clicking so well which
makes this a really complicated thing to
[ __ ] talk about it's just the way
people have been reporting on this thing
is just like [ __ ] hate boners rather
than people being excited about cool
tech that frankly they should not buy
you shouldn't buy this I I will say that
I don't think that you should buy a
Google stadia right now let's I don't
think it's good value for money I don't
think that's worth complaining about
because you can just make the choice not
to buy it but it's also that it's very
hit and miss and inconsistent and
there's no guarantee it'll work for you
I'm frankly glad to have it I really
like that at any point I can go to
stadia calm and play a game and I can do
the same thing at my office and it
immediately starts up and I don't have
to wait for a [ __ ] download because
downloads suck and it has worked for me
really consistently and I'm happy about
that but I can't guarantee the same
experience for anyone else and that's I
can't tell you to buy it I also just
yeah for sales purposes hope that they
do eventually make it more of a game
pause subscription model where you're
paying a subscription then everything is
free it's also just like I don't know
who this thing is for like it's some
people like me right like I really care
about the games industry and I care
about the future of technology and I
care about I don't like any of that
I don't like it I don't like it when
things of frozen Sakura made me scared
what sets this apart from other game
streaming services nothing it's just the
first one that I had my hands on I think
X cloud people have really liked it but
I haven't a chance to try it so there's
nothing that's that's it
yeah I feel like it's made for people
like me who are very excited about tech
and wanted to check it out and want to
see the evolution of that tech and play
video games constantly but that's
obviously not sustainable I don't I
don't know who stayed here thought it
would be I [ __ ] hate this I don't
know who think the stadia thought it
will working to drive it I don't know
who stadia thought it would be for that
is who I think it is poised for a very
particular very hardcore audience I hate
this the I'm spooked okay [ __ ] it
Oh cutscene that's comforting uh Vic us
any noticeable input delay if you have
an average connection I've seen a lot of
people with a lot of different accounts
of like how it's been for them there are
people who've been at who've had average
connections that have said it's run
great for them so it seems to be all
over the place I really done done
Tom l said stadia needs a hard-line
connection Wi-Fi isn't good enough I am
running on Wi-Fi my PC is not hardwired
this whole video has been running on
Wi-Fi so that is objectively false
I agree Eddy that some people's
connections would not be fast enough I
have repeatedly said that Savage mantas
said should never support a company with
such greedy pricing regardless of
performance I vehemently disagree with
your hypothesis there so I am NOT
supporting this company I am just
talking about my experience with a
product honestly I refuse to lie about
my experience with this product that
would be disingenuous and frankly would
invalidate the entire purpose of my
[ __ ] job forever so I am NOT
supporting the company I am giving an
honest look into my experience with the
product I absolutely think that when
companies do something go to something
bad regardless of their pricing models
that we should openly talk about them
it's like saying you can't talk about
let me actually move this frame so that
it and I when it's like that you can see
the whole thing that's like saying that
because we don't like
because they have so many
microtransactions and games that I can
never talk about anything good that ei
does and a lot of the people who consume
video game media do tend to have that
attitude and it [ __ ] sucks a lot of
them will be like how dare you say
something about ei that's a positive you
shill but I strongly believe that we
should talk about the positive and
negative things that any individual
company does and talking about the
positive thing does not mean that you
support the negative things I just think
it's such a closed minded way that
people consume games media that they
just want you to be angry at someone for
one thing that they've done but things
aren't that black-and-white so like EA
has the what is it EA originals program
the EA originals program is incredible
everyone hates EA a lot I get why there
are a lot of reasons that I don't like
EA really strongly frankly EA originals
is the program that a way out is a part
of and unravel actually unravel didn't
apply but it is the thing that spawned
it what's the other one the game with
the little fox thing I don't remember
the name of the game but originals is
amazing because the indie devs who make
those games take a hundred cent profit
yeah it takes back the amount of money
they spent on marketing but the devs
take 100% profit from the games and they
get to retain their IP it is an
incredible program for EA and when I was
at IGN I wrote two positive things about
EA originals and people just told me to
shut the [ __ ] up stop talking about EA
positively and it's such a bad thing
about the games community is that it
sometimes you feel like people don't
actually want to be informed they don't
actually want to know the truth about
things they just want you to yell at
things like people don't actually want
me to show them whatever is good about
stadia or that my experience with stadia
is pretty smooth and give them my
impressions and where I'm coming from
with those impressions very candidly
they just want me to say the thing is
[ __ ] bad and that's how I'll get more
views and how people not be mad at me
and it's such a frustrating thing like
you people talk about wanting you to be
positive sorry wanting you to be honest
having issues with games journalists not
being honest but then when you are
honest they get really [ __ ] angry at
you
it's just like sure yes EA killed
Visceral Games and dead space they did I
don't agree with that but I don't know
why I can't talk positively about EA
originals just because
they shut down Visceral Games all-righty
friends I'm going to end the scapegoat a
bit I'm Ilana I'll see you guys next
time okay